[Music]
unemployment claims are surging as
businesses shut their doors during this
pandemic our national correspondent
Jericka Duncan has been talking to small
business owners and laid off employees
who are trying to stay afloat jurika
good morning good morning to you that
are fixing closures right now the
staggering in fact some experts predict
that 7 million people could lose their
jobs between April and June and the
unemployment rate is expected to
skyrocket to 90 percent by later this
year for many it is just unclear right
now how long the economy and their
livelihoods will be paralyzed by this
pandemic Greg Fletcher and his business
partners spent two years preparing to
open ax an Arab brewery in New Jersey
now just two weeks away from their
one-year anniversary the business is
facing an uncertain future what's your
concern I mean there's a real threat to
a lot of small businesses we're paycheck
to paycheck week to week that revenue
has to come in or it's it's problematic
Fletcher says they have a small cash
reserve and their customers are still
able to pick up beer to go when we
talked to him Sunday afternoon
he'd only made two sales that day one
during our interview it's it's working
yeah this obviously extends out into
three weeks it's not going to be enough
to cover all of our expenses he stopped
scheduling his four part-time employees
as businesses around the country faced
the same tough decisions the closures
have been especially hard on retail
hospitality restaurant and travel
industries roughly 82 million people
that's three fifths of the US workforce
our hourly employees most won't be paid
if they don't work I'm scared
Kanika rice worked at Johns Hopkins
University as a cook but is now out of a
job
she says she makes 65 percent less on
unemployment
compared to her regular pay and says
it's not enough
support her three children what I get in
unemployment is just enough to survive
Kelly and Nathan who asked us not to use
their last names decided to leave New
York City to move in with family in
Virginia Nathan lost his job as a
coordinator for a non-profit Kelley's
job and retail e-commerce was furloughed
without pay
it's all very uncertain at this point
but yeah you know if and when I get the
call to come back to work I will be
there without a doubt full disclosure
Kelly is my cousin but as you all know
this pandemic is infecting everyone you
know here's something else to consider
when you talk about the economy 18
million people pay more than half of
their income to their housing so take
that into consideration you miss a
paycheck and now you're looking at not
being able to pay your rent or your
mortgage experts saying that you should
reach out to your banks and also your
landlord to see what kind of
arrangements you can make to delay those
payments if needed
yeah Jericka that's that's well taken I
mean if you skip the virus everyone is
in fact in fact is infected by the
economic flu that's going around here
thank you very much it's an economic
crisis as well as yeah it does seem
though that people want to be more
accommodating these days I hope that
that is the case yeah indeed they want
to help Yeah right Rica thank